[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the hall of famer
turner sports nba analyst reggie miller
joining us on the program
good morning reg how are you now weren't
we
just a week ago
seven days ago when it was two
nothing phoenix sons everyone in
milwaukee
thought it was over everyone was
about ready to get rid of coach
budenholzer
giannis was going to be a forever choke
artist
and now now they're on the verge of
winning
an nba championship they're first in
what 50 plus years
what a week makes right and didn't you
and i talk about
well phoenix did what they had to do
they secured their home court advantage
went back to milwaukee that's what
milwaukee did
but milwaukee went on the road
got game five and is in total control of
this series
you expect milwaukee to win tuesday
night
i i do unless and there's one caveat
because we have not really seen that
this series
chris paul hasn't had a signature game
yet
and i think we're all waiting on that
booker has been
great but the other half of that
equation
is chris paul he had six signature
moments
versus the lakers versus denver
games i'm talking about and versus the
clippers there was always one game
he had where he was phenomenal
game six it has to be that for him if
not
then this series is over i mentioned
last week that by thursday we're either
going to be talking about
giannis and getting two mvps in a title
at this age which is really really rare
in the history of the sport
or we'll probably be talking about chris
paul finally elevating himself into a
different category
as a point guard i i know devin booker
will be the mvp of phoenix wins and
giannis will be the mvp if the milwaukee
bucks win
but do you think those are still are we
going to be is that fair to chris paul
if let's say the phoenix suns lose this
are we going to look at chris paul as
opposed to
the rest of the team monty williams
um should it all be on chris paul that
hey didn't get
it done again you led two games to none
with home court advantage
at 36 no i think
chris paul will probably get a pass
because of his age and because of the
hard knocks it
has taken chris paul to even get to the
nba finals
and i'm not saying this will be his
last look at it but he will get a long
pass um because of the signature games
along the way
i think people will remember those more
uh as opposed to
he just hasn't played great here in the
finals and
there's still time for him again i i
think he needs to put a stamp and have a
signature
30 plus 12 assists
but in impactful points like he had
versus the clippers in that closeout
game
like he had against denver in that
closeout game those close-up games he
was
phenomenal and we just haven't seen that
and i give all the credit
to drew holliday pj tucker pat
connington those three guys have been
the principal defenders
on cp3 and they've done a great job of
really
just locking him down yeah my point that
i've been making is
that i know we want to focus on the
stars but it's the role players
you can go down through history you can
have great players
there's a role player who does something
whether it's baseball football
like malcolm butler with the patriots
nobody had heard of him
uh you know you get a role player like
john paxton or steve kerr who hits a big
shot you can have star power
it's what kind of contributions am i
getting it feels like milwaukee has
depth that they can rely on and monty
williams isn't sure what he has with
phoenix
and i mentioned pat connington but
people are not talking enough of bobby
portis
jr he has been fantastic throughout
these playoffs
barely sniffed the floor in that
brooklyn series
at all and then comes back in atlanta
and has a huge
huge impact because of the injury
tiana's
and has been fantastic in the finals
here and you're right
i think coach budd and the bucks
they have more luxury because of their
bench
and i think the injury to charge has
has hurt phoenix tory craig has not been
the same since he went down with the leg
injury i know he's played since then
but he hasn't been the same um but look
i'm not gonna count phoenix out because
they've been fantastic on the road
all postseason i think coming into the
nba finals they were six and two on the
road
so they're certainly capable of of
winning
on the road but uh everything has to
fall into place
they got out to a great start in game
five i mean they shot the lights out
can they do that for 48 minutes on the
road danielle then
everything lebron was at the game
and he brought in his own tequila
[Laughter]
i didn't know you're allowed to do that
he had a bottle of tequila underneath
his seat
if you're the king don't you normally
travel with your own tequila
i don't know i would have others who
traveled with my tequila for me but
well i'm sure they were sitting in the
cheap seats they brought the tequila to
the king yeah
store this under your chair your
highness but he was there with
his sip at your leisure and his his
agent is reportedly dating adele
rich paul is reportedly dating adele
and my comment on that would be
good for you rich paul no story here
no story here no confirmation on that
story do you
i have no idea who rich paul is dating
okay
all right just these are things that are
important and and you're aware no
no these things are not important are
you kidding lebron bringing his own
tequila
and adele sitting next to lebron and
rich paul
no lebron bringing his own tequila
that's a cute story rich paul
potentially dating adele that's a
non-story who cares
i do are you entertainment tonight
oh i love adele i want her to be happy
i'm sure rich paul is making her very
happy
[Laughter]
what is damian lillard saying without
saying it
yeah uh portland trailblazers you're on
game time
you're on the clock
i want to see some movement and some
changing okay what changes you brought
in a new coach you've got an
injury-plagued roster here i love
chauncey phillips i had a lot of
headbutting with him and his detroit
pistons
i think he's going to be a fabulous
coach but he's also unproven
so i think that's probably the question
that dame and his camp are having right
now
what could be our level of success with
with chauncey coming in and what kind of
moves can we potentially make
to make us a championship team so
i don't think all these trade rumors i
really
believe they're not coming from dean but
obviously his agent
his boys they're they're being filtrated
out they're not necessarily coming from
him himself
but he's having these conversations with
these people
okay what could portland possibly do to
make him happy
get quiet maybe i mean kawaii's not
gonna play that i mean
what top free agent is out there that
would make him happy
i don't know look dame is a loyal guy
he's always talked about not wanting to
team up and make super teams and
fight the good fight but i also heard kd
say that too
so i don't know i don't think they can
get much better
that's i just don't and and if you're
lillard do you see him forcing his way
out or
them respecting his body of work and
saying you know what you've done so much
for
us we'll probably get less for you but
it's the right thing to do i just can't
see them giving up on a potential top 10
player
and saying okay you've done right by us
for eight years
time for you to go well it's one thing
to have him but then are you using him
correctly it
hey i got uh i got dame
what else you got um not too much you
know we're not threatening
and then what are you building around or
theodore in his defense and he had no
control of this
a lot there's a lot of injuries that
surrounded the trailblazers
that he had zero control of nurkic
collins oh i don't blame him for any of
it i i love watching him play
i'm just saying if i'm damien lillard i
look around
and i realize we're not we're not an
elite team
and we're not going to be an elite team
i think what would be
if i'm damon lillard i look around and i
look at the phoenix suns and saying
they got to the nba finals no knock on
chris paul devin booker
mommy williams great but look at you're
talking about the role players
i mean cameron payne's or craig shaw
they
deandre hayden they got to the nba
finals you tell me
we couldn't have done that that probably
would be more frustrating if i'm lillard
but if you could let's say you could get
let's say ben simmons is available
and you have to you could get somebody
ben simmons doesn't tip the scale for me
to get me over the edge to beat the
lakers
uh utah phoenix denver denver
yeah i don't think ben simmons is that
kind of guy that's gonna
make uh lillard say okay i'm ready to go
i mean unless he gets a jump shot
between now
and october 15th i don't know
but but what if dame is traded and you
get ben simmons in something
like you have to at some point go let's
get younger
because dame is 30. um
you trade him for ben simmons no not
just ben simmons
well ben simmons uh you because you're
you're gonna have to give up
yeah and
maybe another big to get damian lillard
but
you put lillard with tobias harris
and joelle embiid yeah
i like that but you know daryl i like
that
was in philly daryl mori loves to swing
for the fences
the gm and the sixers i i gotta believe
somebody's gonna swing for the fences
you know would the knicks do
with the knicks try to pull something
off wouldn't you
how would damian lillard you know be in
the garden with that young team it
depends on on the
young team who you've given up are you
giving up r.j barrett probably because
i assume he'd probably have to be in
that do you yeah are you keeping
julius randle it depends on the pieces i
i think what new york and the knicks did
this year was great
they made it more appealing for free
agents to potentially think
all right new york is not as bad as
place as they've been over the last 10
plus years
i could give them a shot but there's
other teams like
the philadelphia if you're more a in
philly
because here's the thing the brooklyn
nets
are only going to get better and
hopefully knock on wood
stay healthier with kyrie
and james harden and obviously kd
so right now they're i put them as the
best team in the
in the east but if you add lillard to
philadelphia
with joelle i mean that's a different
story
that's a different story now talking to
reggie miller the hall of famer uh
you won a gold medal i think he had uh
20 points in that gold medal game in 96.
something
something like that i mean 22 20 i mean
i'm not 26
i don't know i can't remember i was
getting buckets
versus yugoslavia yes you had grant hill
you had hardaway it did yeah jack
he was an american citizen by then oh
man that's a great acquisition
hey our sinners shaq david robinson
hakeem elijah
in 96 in atlanta was carl malone on that
team
carl malone charles scotty mitch richman
grant hardaway and hardaway
and gary payton dang we had a squad
we had a squad okay how would that team
do against the dream team
that would have been a good matchup i
we win by
three
i don't know i would love to have seen
it
but because some players on 92 were on
96. so who you
you know well barclays got to be on the
dream team
you you lose him and carl's on the dream
team
and stockton and pippen are on the next
oh
yeah so we okay we lose by 15.
[Laughter]
but but when you play on a team like
that how do you decide
like who is the go-to guy charles was
you know
great on the dream team he was i think
the leading scorer in the dream team but
how do you decide without acknowledging
hey
this is the go-to guy or this is the guy
we're gonna uh
okay there were some games a lot of
teams played zone against us because
they were afraid of shaq and robinson
and
akeem so they packed it in and played
zone those were my knights that
me and mitch we were like salivating oh
you guys going to play the zone against
us
and we're pure shooters it's great and
there's other times when teams played
man-to-man
and you know we just gave it to carl and
shaq
and and big fella and
charles and they just went crazy down
low so we we wouldn't gain my game and
there was really
there were there weren't any egos we
were just out there to have fun and
win a gold medal and we achieved that
did you
did you have any beefs with those guys
and then they become your teammates
zero zero but going into it before
being on the dr the olympic team
uh there had to be some guys who hated
you
well they may have hated me but i didn't
hate them
i don't know i i got a chance to to know
uh john stockton you know because
you know you hear a lot of things you
know you've only played utah twice and
he was you know somewhat of a i wouldn't
say dirty player but
it was all about you know it was all
about winning and i
to get a chance to know him and his
family same with carl
to get a chance to know those kind of
guys was kind of cool
from my hand you lead the team in three
point
attempts i'm gonna guess i hope so yeah
look it up paulie paulie yeah i did what
did i average on dream team in 96 i
hadn't been won the leading scorer
yeah you were 11.4 points per game
barkley was 12.4
dave robinson was 12. so you though you
threw the top scorers
you were the lowest amount of turnovers
on the entire team
because i wasn't passing to those
selfish dudes
but does shaq say give me the ball at
any point
yeah jack got upset with me one time
during the olympics
it wasn't a b but like i kept feeding
david robinson
and a king right and then shaq comes in
he's like what
okay you're going through them you're
not going to feed me
what's going on so this is why to this
day i tell them this is why you took it
out on us in the finals right
and you know between the bases this is
why he's like no
reg you know i just wanted to show rick
smith i was like no you're getting me
back from 96
right for not feeding you the ball down
low he's like
you know i'm the best center out here
with david robinson and nokia one i'm
the best sitter out here
give me the ball feed me the ball
[Laughter]
did was it how different was it to play
in the finals like the
the pressure to play in an nba finals as
opposed to
an eastern conference finals or first
round of a playoff game
like you know
every possession you hear this all the
time it takes a life of its own
i had a horrendous horrible
game one and to me to this day just
it it bugs and irks me
that my game one performance to me
affected
our team the rest of the series i
thought
i shot one for 13 um
had like 12 13 points but that set the
tone
because i i have always been the guy
if we would have if i would have played
well and we have lost
that still would have gave the rest of
the guys hope
it's all a mental it's all mental but
why did you play
the rest of the series i played great
the rest of the series but to me
that game one just haunts me it just
i should have i should have been better
in that game one just to put something
on kobe's and shaq's mind and i didn't
and that it just bugs me why did you
play poorly
i i i didn't shoot the ball well
you know what maybe i excelled a little
bit because we had just
beaten the knicks we got past our arch
nemesis
nemesis and i excelled
and that's what i should have took three
or four more deeper
breaths and then like okay now we're in
the finals
and i exhaled for a moment and
it cost me in game one again i played
fine the rest of the series but to me
you know there's certain moments in
certain games i always remember more
that game won i just wish i could have
back yeah it's 21 years ago shaq
uh put up 43 and 19 i think
and how many free uh polly how many free
throws did he shoot
that game one of the games he shot 39
free throws how many free throws
because we he must have shot at least 25
in that game
in game one shaq was uh one for six from
the free-throw line
that's it yep what was the game when he
shot like 39 free throws
checking he shot 39 free throws in the
finals
a game in the finals
30 something wow yeah paul game two
shaq had 40 points 24 rebounds he was
18-39 from the free-throw line
46 18 of 39.
39 free throws
he went through rick perkins
we're just gonna put him on the line we
had
zero and we were treating him like
giannis 39
39 free throws yeah paulie and we still
and we still lost
reggie in that entire nba finals you
missed one free throw
you were 45 of 46.
it bugs me it bugs me
one free throw are you kidding me
that's unacceptable it is damn you know
you're a shooter
it is unacceptable what did shaq
shoot from the line in the nba finals
for the series he was
36 of 93. oh my god
and we're talking about giannis he
missed more that week than reggie missed
in his life
you didn't miss that many free throws in
your career reg
oh my god dominant
he was we had no answer for shot
it was young kobe so i could still
i could get to kobe a little bit he put
on when shaq fouled out
of game four and kobe took over
see you're making me have therapy
and have therapy on air that's another
moment
like i just wish we could have back
that when shaq fouled out
god and we went to overtime that was
our chance to tie this series up 2-2 and
game five that's when it went 2-3-2 yeah
game 5 is in our building if we win that
which we did
we go up 3-2 coming home and then we got
to win one of two
it's great to talk to you
i today you
enjoy the rest of your day reg oh yeah
it's gonna be chipper now
yeah on my bike ride all i'm gonna be
thinking about
and going one for 13 in game one oh
great he's reggie miller hall of famer
joining us
thank you reg i love it love you dan
ants i'm going to iceland we're gonna
we'll uh we'll take a break back after
this